how did someone who gets so much
basic chemistry wrong discover such
a breakthrough unique first
of their kind formulation?
you might have seen matter of fact on your
social media lately they're a skincare brand
their star product is a vitamin c serum and
they've been doing a lot of sponsorships
with influencers particularly the
ones that come across as sciencey
you might have been surprised to see me
in one of their influencer ads recently
i was surprised too because no one asked me and
three months earlier i told their founder exactly
why i didn't want to do a sponsorship
with them or endorse them in any way
so today i'm interrupting our regular viewing
schedule to talk about how matter of fact
annoyed me enough to pause
the endless list of content
that i'm meant to be working on to
spend literal days making this video
have you noticed that skincare
science has gotten really trendy?
for us as skin care users it makes sense
we want to use products that actually work
and understanding the science behind how products
work is a really good way of going about it you
can find out what does and doesn't matter
so you can focus on which products actually
make sense for your skin and your life
and learning science is just kind of fun
i think skincare science really got trendy with
the ordinary suddenly we all had a reason to
learn these complex ingredient names because
each product cost less than ten dollars and
while that was cool i really liked that we all
found each other and got to nerd out together
it also meant a lot of brands saw this and
started thinking hmm how do we get in on this
babe what are you doing?
like and subscribe to help
me buy a lock for my room
look using science to sell products isn't
anything new on one level it makes perfect
sense if a brand has invested a lot of time and
money into making sure their product works well
then explaining to people how it works
showing them all the testing they've done
is a really great way to show people
why they should choose that product
and if science is really trendy
then people are more interested in
the details and the brand can show more
of the data that they normally wouldn't
which is great for me i'm really nosy
but science is hard you have to study and do lab
classes and learn stuff and read papers properly
or if you don't want to do that then you
have to hire scientists and they take
ages to do stuff plus you have
to pay them the whole time
why did it take 300 years to get just one
number there i did that in like five seconds
so what if we just
and that's where sciencewashing comes in
sciencewashing is where you take the aesthetic
of science and make things look scientific
without actually doing the science part
things like talking about studies
that aren't interpreted correctly
citing studies that aren't relevant and hoping no
one looks into them using scientific words to try
to sound smart but using them incorrectly using
numbers and graphs that don't really make sense
you get the science cred without actually
having to deal with the rest of the iceberg
and it makes a lot of sense
from a profit perspective
mathematical
and here we come to matter
of fact who are one of the
most sciencewashed brands i think i've ever seen
matter of fact is a skincare brand that
claims to be moving the science of skin
care forward with evidence-based breakthrough
technologies their star product is a vitamin
c serum that they say is the most significant
advancement in skin care in nearly two decades
with unmatched stability potency and cosmetic
elegance this is a big deal because vitamin c
is an incredible skincare ingredient but
it breaks down very quickly in products
their founder is paul baek their launch email
describes him as a true multi-hyphenate with
degrees from harvard and wharton (his degrees are
in psychology and business) and a successful k-pop
career on his resume he also worked for two years
in venture capital which he doesn't mention much
he was also mentored in cosmetic formulation
specifically emulsion technology he says he
first got behind a bench in 2018 but in a
few short months he had already made this
20-year breakthrough in chemistry without
any proper chemistry training except his
mom has a chemistry phd (that keeps coming up)
he outsmarted all of the thousands of
qualified scientists in the cosmetics
industry and his discovery wasn't even
in emulsions the thing he was mentored in
foreshadowing
amazing that explains why his press release says
he has a rare yet brilliant
mind for both science and art
i first noticed matter of fact when i saw the
hype around their launch in september 2021
their ads made some really bold
claims about their ascorbic acid serum
it has unmatched stability in the vitamin c
space the ascorbic acid was fully stabilized
since i am a massive vitamin
c nerd i was really curious
here's their graph showing the
stability of their formula versus
"the current gold standard
with regard to stability"
so the obvious question is what
product are they comparing it with?
well it seems like it has to be the
skinceuticals c e ferulic it's the
only vitamin c product anyone calls
the gold standard but it isn't the
gold standard for stability it's the
gold standard for effectiveness on skin
c e ferulic is water-based and water-based
vitamin c serums have a serious disadvantage
when it comes to stability because water
makes ascorbic acid decompose faster
matter of fact actually mention this all the time
so they're comparing their
waterless vitamin c serum to
a water-based vitamin c serum which is a
different less stable category of product
it's a bit like saying ronnie baker beat
the gold standard caeleb dressel so he's
unmatched in the hundred metres and then you
realize ronnie baker is a sprinter and caeleb
dressel is a swimmer caeleb and the water-based
formula are both fighting against extra water
i'm pretty proud of that analogy
so this is really not good evidence
for showing that your product is
more stable than every other product on the market
so i mildly pestered them about what data
they had for their unmatched stability claim
paul eventually replied to
my email six weeks later
we had a two-hour meeting where
we talked about the brand and the
studies they'd done and he confirmed that
the other serum in the graph is water-based
he said they tested against three products
in total two water-based and one water-free
i don't think you need to know that
much about science to know that
if you test against just three products and
only one of them is in the same category as
yours that doesn't tell you that your product
is the best out of all the thousands of products
out there especially since you don't know how
long those other products have been sitting on
the shelf breaking down and turning into
stuff that can make it break down faster
and based on the science you wouldn't really
expect this to be the most stable product for
example there are silicone-based
vitamin c products like this one
from the ordinary a lot of these use
a raw material called granactive aa20
which claims to be 90% stable for three
months at 40 degrees in an open container
to me as a chemist it seems incredibly unlikely
that ascorbic acid dissolved in propanediol can
compete with that propanediol is a humectant
moisturiser and that is really good at absorbing
water so if you put this in an open container with
any amount of humidity it's going to absorb water
from the air that means even if you start off
with pure propanediol with no water you're going
to end up with propanediol and water and that
water from the air is going to make the ascorbic
acid decompose a lot faster the propanediol
is basically moisturizing the ascorbic acid
silicone is the opposite silicone can form a
waterproof layer around the ascorbic acid which
protects it from water it's an occlusive and in
this case the silicone is sealing the water out
the fact that this serum has dissolved ascorbic
acid will also make it break down faster the
ascorbic acid can move around a lot more when
it's dissolved which means a lot more will be
available to react compared to when it's in solid
grains in a thick suspension so it doesn't really
make a lot of sense to say this has "unmatched
stability in the vitamin c space" unless you have
a lot of very convincing evidence to back you
up all of the science that we know about these
ingredients so far goes against that claim
so you're going to want to have very strong
evidence to overturn that testing against just
one water free product just isn't going to cut it
we also talked about the rest of their marketing
i only just noticed this but the inside
of the box lid says facts matter which
is interesting considering
well the rest of this video
there is a lot of incorrect science in
their instagram posts that i think again
just really seems to highlight that there's
some basic scientific understanding and just
really caring enough to factcheck missing
for example there's this post about why vitamin
c serums turn brown as they oxidise they say it's
because ascorbic acid turns into erythrulose and
they say erythrulose is reddish brown i explained
how this wasn't correct in my instagram stories
erythrulose isn't reddish brown and there's
no way this could be reddish brown this is
something we teach in high school chemistry
for a molecule to be strongly coloured it
needs to have something in its structure
that can absorb specific colours of
light and this just doesn't have that
about a week after this paul did a live
where he showed the manufacturer spec
sheets saying that 75 to 80% erythrulose is
yellow to orange again i feel like this is
pretty basic if i have a cup of water
that's not pure water and it's coloured
it's not the colourless water making it
coloured it's something else in that glass
and in an oxidized vitamin c serum you have maybe
five percent erythrulose max it's nowhere near
intense enough to be contributing to the colour
change like they said when they fixed the post
i also love that they mentioned the confusion
like they weren't the ones who were confused
there's also this three-step thing
paul's mentioned it in an interview
as well but ascorbic acid decomposes
through way more than three steps
plus it turns into tons of different
chemicals not just erythrulose
i think this might be because he misinterpreted
one of my blog posts back in 2017 a lot of people
were asking me why vitamin c seems to stain your
fingers people were worried that it was pigment or
something dangerous happening i found this diagram
in a paper showing ascorbic acid turning into a
bunch of different things including erythrulose
which is a common fake tan ingredient this made
a lot of sense because vitamin c stays look
and act a lot like fake tan so i figured it was
probably the erythrulose or some other similar
chemical in the vitamin c serum causing it
so i did a blog post and i redrew just
those three steps from ascorbic acid
to erythrulose to make it a bit clearer because
this diagram is just too much for anyone who just
wants to know why their fingers are yellow dammit
i linked the paper and i wrote
this little paragraph to clarify
that erythrulose wasn't the only product
there are lots of different products and
there are way more than three steps
involved but i think paul didn't
understand it and he thought what i drew
was everything because it turned into this
so in my meeting with paul he also said that he's
a big fan of my work he mentioned specific blog
posts that he liked and even my reddit username
i made a joke that i should maybe invoice him for
all this free advice and he said he wanted
to pay me to make sponsored posts and also
discuss hiring me to work for matter of
fact he wanted me to help them design
experiments to test their products and
check the claims in their marketing
this last part was pretty sus to me i've been
making science content for a long time i think
i'm really good at communicating skincare science
but i'm not a regulatory expert i'm not a cosmetic
claims expert beyond what i did in my diploma
and the regulatory certificate that i'm studying
there are scientists who have been working
in the industry for decades whose job this is
why would you hire a skin care science
influencer without the right expertise for this
his reason was that regulatory and claims
people weren't good at communicating and he
wanted someone who could communicate well but
then you should hire multiple people scientists
are specialised for a reason you can't hire a
biologist to do chemistry you can't hire a science
communicator and expect them to deal with all
of this very industry specific stuff accurately
and if you are genuinely dedicated to getting the
right information out there empowering people with
science why would you only start hiring people
to check the science three months after launching
this brand has 10 million in investor funding
they can afford to do all of these really big
influencer sponsorships they should have
plenty of budget to pay a random chemist a
couple hundred a month to just quickly check
their instagram posts before they go live
the fact they don't have this this just seems
to me like really messed up priorities for
a brand that claims they want to demystify
skin care science so this was a big red flag
so i suggested i could help them with
their science communication but not in a
public-facing way he could pay me a rate that
was much lower than my sponsored post rate to
just fact check their posts before they went up
and then maybe later down the line i could do
public sponsored content once their content
was something i was more comfortable with
but paul wasn't interested in that and that
seemed to me like a pretty big indication
that what they really wanted was to use me
and my reputation to get them to look good
and scientific rather than caring about actually
being scientific and putting out accurate
information they wanted the veneer of credibility
without doing any of the hard work to earn it
so i said if you wanted to be a
scientific brand that i'd feel
comfortable endorsing they should
fix three things firstly fix their
stability claims because they didn't
have the data to make those claims
secondly actually fact-check their posts properly
before posting so no more of this erythrulose kind
of thing if you genuinely want to educate people
but you're not sure about something then just
don't post rather than misinforming people just
for the sake of engagement and gaining followers
thirdly stop making drug claims in
their posts and their sponsored posts
drug claims are when you say your
product changes the structure or
function of skin rather than just
the appearance or treating a disease
if your product is a cosmetic and not a drug
then you shouldn't be making these claims
this includes reducing pigment reducing wrinkles
promoting collagen production treating melasma
and it includes linking studies where your
active ingredient does these drug things
i know it kind of seems like it should be fine
to just state facts but there are regulations
around this because drugs go through really
rigorous testing to make sure they actually work
small studies aren't enough to
back up these strong drug claims
this is the sort of thing that
happens with illegal drug claims
a lot of skin care brands do make
some degree of drug claims but
if you're a brand that claims to be scientific
and ethical and moving skin care forward
then i think you should really be on top
of this and you especially shouldn't be
making the stronger drug claims that the
vast majority of brands know not to make
for sponsored posts where a brand has paid
an influencer to talk about their product
influencers generally don't know the
difference between drug and cosmetic claims
brands have to sign off on the final
draft of sponsored content before it
goes live so i really think it's the brand's
responsibility to hire a regulatory consultant
and check that all the claims
they're making are above board
a lot of brands seem to think that if
the influencer makes the drug claims and
sponsored content then it's not their fault but
no that is not a loophole it still counts as the
brand's marketing claims just like with any
regular ad this is in the ftc guidelines and
both the brand and the influencer are at fault
paul agreed that these would be good changes
to make i agreed to have another meeting
in the future to discuss working with them
again and i go off on my merry way feeling
okay i guess about giving free advice to
a brand for two hours but they did seem
to want to do better and hopefully this would
improve the state of misinformation in skincare
and then a couple months later i
go back and check what happened
for point 1 all the unmatched
stability claims are still up
for point 2 which was not making really basic
easily checked mistakes they've now done a post
where they used a reference because yes citing
things will make us look credible and sciencey
but they don't seem to understand how
references work and it kind of looks
like they've never seen a reference
before in their life either that or
they really felt strongly about leslie
doing three people's worth of work
and then after i posted a
story about this they tried
to fix it but then turned her into baumann leslie
and then after i posted a story
about that they tried to fix it
again and doubled up the title it
still looks like that by the way
they also put the molecular structure of retinol
in a post because chemical structures are science
but they chopped off half the retinol molecule
which makes it a completely different chemical
they actually managed to get rid of the bit
that makes retinOL so i guess this is reti
hot tip for brands if you're going to use chemical
structures to science up your brand's marketing
the bare minimum you should do is a
three second google for the structure
and then instead of owning up to
the mistake they dug deeper and said
you're right our design team made a stylistic
choice to zoom in on half of the molecule
due to its long structure when we focus
grouped it with some of our audience members
they didn't mind since the molecular
structure was unfamiliar to them
i feel like this should go without
saying but you can't change the way
chemical structures work just
because you focus grouped it
the structure is the molecule
this isn't retinol anymore
it's like labeling this as africa
because your focus group said it was fine
and on point three they've now gotten
influencers to make sponsored posts
comparing their active ingredient to
hydroquinone which is a prescription drug
so i wrote an email to paul on january 26 about
all of these issues and i still haven't gotten
a reply even though they clearly saw it and
went through and fixed everything i mentioned
well they tried to fix it anyway
and then on march 13 i get tagged in a sponsored
post that an influencer made for matter of fact
it says they advocate for women in
science like me for women's history
month and of course to buy their
products for the women in your life
on the face of it this is kind of like a nice
shout out from the influencer who didn't know all
of this stuff going on behind the scenes although
it is a bit weird slash against advertising
codes to put someone in a sponsored post that
you're being paid for without asking them first
but the way influencer sponsorships work is
that the influencer sends the final draft
to the brand and then they sign off on it
before it goes live so matter of fact would
have seen me in the draft post and approved
this after all of these interactions with them
and still without replying to my email about poor
amputated reti after 40 days also without checking
if they could legally use someone in an ad without
their consent and even though this isn't an ad
specifically for their products it is still an
ad lots of companies do ads where they talk about
their values so you can feel good about them and
buy their products and i don't know why matter of
fact thought i would be comfortable being used
to improve their public image after all of this
obviously i complained about this
and they eventually took it down
after about two days again without any
sort of communication with me no apology
i had to ask the influencer to contact
matter of fact also they blocked my
comments from showing up in their post
which is amazing advocacy for me i think
i guess the extremely obvious
question we're building up to here
is how did someone who gets so much
basic chemistry wrong discover such
a breakthrough unique first of their kind
formulation how did paul baek whose only
chemistry background is essentially his mum
and his "rare and brilliant mind" outsmart
all of the qualified chemists in the cosmetics
industry "crack the elusive code" and create
"the most significant advancement in skincare
in nearly two decades" after just a few months?
well if you look at matter of fact's
vitamin c patent which as of now
is still pending it seems like he kind of didn't
this is the breakthrough
that paul claims to have made
PB: it just boiled down to: is there a way to
dissolve high concentrations of ascorbic acid
in solvents that are not water that's sort of
where i started and through a lot of
experimentation found a way to do it
PB: the eureka moment was thinking
about other ingredients that were not
liquid at room temperature
potentially being co-solvents
and using that framework allowed us
to sort of create this new technology
so he's saying he's worked out how to get
more ascorbic acid to dissolve without water
you can only get about 12% ascorbic acid to
dissolve in propanediol but if you add urea
you can get over 20% to dissolve so
that's what the matter of fact serum does
which sounds really neat but
someone else already discovered this
17 years ago
and it isn't like matter of
fact aren't aware of this
they reference them extensively
in their own patent application
even without much science or chemistry
knowledge i think it's pretty obvious
that this 2007 patent is about using urea
to help ascorbic acid dissolve in polyol
apart from this which
someone else discovered first
i can't really see what's so innovative
or breakthrough about this formula
it has other antioxidants ferulic acid and
a plant extract but every other vitamin c
serum on the market also has antioxidants the
2007 patent covers formulas with antioxidants
maybe it's the fact this combination is stable but
testing someone else's discovery
doesn't mean you discovered it
it looks like Paul might have seen what he thought
was a potential loophole and tried to file a
patent for that the two 2007 zhang patents listed
examples of polyol solvents that were covered
but one of the patents didn't list 1,3-propanediol
which is the solvent used in matter of fact
matter of fact mention this specifically
several times in their claims
i'm guessing zhang might have left
it out because it wasn't a common
skincare ingredient back then or
maybe he just forgot because he
did list it in his other patent and
it's covered under polyols anyway
here are all the polyols that
zhang listed in his patent claim
and here's matter of fact's 1,3-propanediol
i'm not a patent attorney so i don't know if
this patent will get past pending the rule is
that patents need to be novel and not a trivial
or routine advancement on an existing patent
if it's very similar to an older patent they
often decide that it's covered by the original
if this is what he's claiming to have
discovered - what's essentially a typo
and i would think it's covered
under the old patent anyway -
legality aside this just doesn't
seem much like a eureka moment to me
1,2-propanediol 1,3-propanediol and
1,3-butanediol are really similar
chemicals as you can guess from their names
they're used interchangeably in skincare
it really doesn't seem to me that this is "a truly
new technology" or that paul actually created it
"biggest breakthrough in two decades"
seems like a pretty big stretch
so at the end of all of this is matter
of fact's formula "fully stabilised" with
"unmatched stability"? well i don't think so
i was sent these bottles in
december they expire in august
2023 so i'm guessing they were made august 2021
and they've already started going a lot yellower
than when i first got them i talked to someone
else who was sent the products around the same
time and theirs is actually even more yellow
you can see how colourless they're
meant to be in their promo videos
compared to these other products that i've had for
years well you can see the difference in colour
and i think that's because maybe they didn't test
the product properly under real-life conditions
all the data they show for their stability
claims are with accelerated testing
so they kept the product for
8 weeks at 40 degrees celsius
to approximate what would happen
for 16 months at room temperature
things react faster at higher temperatures so
we use accelerated testing to get an idea of
whether something's likely to go wrong with
the product without having to wait as long
but it's still an approximation things happen at
room temperature that don't happen at
40 degrees and vice versa all the time
and this is particularly important for vitamin c
its degradation depends a lot on temperature so
accelerated testing is a lot
more inaccurate than normal
and you can't really say that these are equivalent
but matter of fact don't seem to know or maybe
they don't care about this pretty important caveat
they hardly ever mention it's approximate they
just keep saying it's been tested for 16 months
and i think the packaging is another big
issue heat doesn't speed up how quickly
oxygen and water leak into your packaging
the same way it speeds up chemical reactions
this is an airless pump but most airless pumps
aren't properly airtight in a standard airless
pump which is what this looks like air can get
through the seams and through the pump dispenser
and given how easily the pump top came off when
i opened the tube a few days ago i'm not really
convinced this connection is tight enough to
keep propanediol free from water and oxygen
and before anyone says i'm being unfair because
i made it oxidise by opening it up i showed you
the serum from this tube which i don't know how
to open and it's the same colour as the other
tubes i have so these claims of 16-month 24-month
stability aren't really backed up by their testing
again i don't blame influencers for this
these are things about vitamin c that i
didn't know five years ago even with a
chemistry phd even though i was so deep
in skincare science i know cosmetic
chemists with decades of experience
who don't know this stuff because
they haven't worked with vitamin c
this is why expertise is specific there's just
way too much information to know everything at
some point you have to trust what
experts say you have to trust that
people presenting themselves as experts
are responsible and self-aware enough
to say when they don't know something
to check with someone who knows more
matter of fact and paul gave them this
info and signed off on their posts
they're meant to know what they're doing here's
the guy who made the biggest discovery in two
decades they're the brand moving the signs
of skin care forward and empowering consumers
and this is really the root of what's wrong with
sciencewashing people and brands who pretend to
be experts but continually put out misinformation
because they want to save time or money or look
smart they make us so much harder for consumers
to work out who to trust and which products to use
i love talking about skincare science
i love that so many more people care
about it now i love that we have
a beauty science nerd community
i love that i've met a lot of really inspiring
experts and science communicators through this
but i can't deny that there was a lot less
misinformation and it was a lot easier to
spot the misinformation before everyone
decided they needed to "science things up"